foreign
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with
economics correspondent at The Spectator
Kate Andrews and the guardian columnist
Zoe Williams
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now here we go is
the front of the Metro as they look
ahead to team England's next World Cup
challenge against reigning Champions
France
the front of the Daily Mail pictures
players bakayasaka Phil foden and Harry
Kane as they celebrate England's win
against Senegal
energy firms Target homes in fuel
poverty reach the front of the eye as it
estimates more than half a million
households are deeply in debt over their
energy bills
the financial times reports that Ursula
Von delayne saying the EU needs to
simplify and adapt its rules on state
aid in response to America's green
energy subsidy scheme
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
Kate Andrews and Zoe Williams welcome to
you both let's start off with the mail
and the headline front page their moans
threats over covid firm now this is um
off the back of Matt Hancock's uh book
that's being serialized in the mail he's
revealing various secrets
Kate
uh so the latest secret I suppose to
drop uh from Matt Hancock's pandemic
Diaries is his claim that Tori Pierre
Michelle moon in his words was
extraordinarily aggressive about
lobbying to try to get one of the
contracts at the height of kovid to
supply lateral flow tests this isn't the
first time we've heard this accusation
against baroness moan there are reports
over the week weekend from so-called
Whitehall sources uh that she had been
aggressive towards people like Michael
Gove who was in cabinet at the time over
PPE contracts as well there have been
questions in the past about her
connections to certain companies and
offshore bank accounts so this is not
the first time that she's been caught up
in say a financial or lobbying
controversy but it seems from the mail
in its serialization of parts of this
book that he is taking the side of of
Michael Gove and suggesting that um you
know indeed yes this kind of lobbying
was happening which is going to be very
uncomfortable uh for the Tory government
especially as there are growing
questions Around the House of Lords
who's being appointed to it how those
people get appointed what the process is
and the Integrity that Rishi neck has
promised to bring to the job of course
he won't in any way be directly
responsible for fairness moan's um
claimed lobbying it should be noted that
she has been insistent so far that she
is innocent
um but it you know it's yet another
Scandal under a Tory government from a
Tory Pier that's going to make the
government uneasy yes and we should say
that uh Banner Smith is under
investigation by the House of Lords
Commissioners for standards
um what's your take on this Zoe does it
matter that these uh details are coming
from Matt Hancock
these are really important understory
here which is that Matt Hancock's trying
to rehabilitate rehabilitate himself
with this kind of thoughts and all
telling of the covid of the of his
covered response as well as you know his
appearance on I'm a celebrity the truth
is he was Health secretary right he
didn't have to respond to her frenzied
emails he didn't have to give her this
contract worth millions of pounds he
didn't have to kind of bow down to the
way she was behaving and clearly she's
very emotionally dysregulated no never
mind the the kind of specific
misdemeanors that she's under
investigation for she's been well known
as a sort of histrionic
um you know very dysregulated
personality for a really long time and
that's come out in interviews time and
time again so I I I'm very resistant to
a narrative in which she comes off as
the bad guy and Matt Hancock comes off
as this you know bullied Health
secretary he was a cabinet minister he
should have been resistant and trenching
in his stance that government contracts
went to reputable businesses and the
fact that he's giving a what's an all
Memoir of it shouldn't really make any
difference
do you agree with that Kate go ahead go
ahead well I would just jump in there
and say according to the mail
um he says that he did not reply to
those aggressive text messages and that
she they were getting more aggressive
because he wasn't giving those contracts
and that's according to the mail uh that
at one point he just says I'm not going
to reply uh so I'm I'm not sure that we
can lay the full blame at Matt Hancock's
feet but I completely agree with Zoe
um that what we are looking at when we
look at these pandemic uh Diaries when
we look at these excerpts
um is a man who's desperately trying to
clear his name and get back in the good
graces of the public and of course he
lost those good graces well for many
reasons throughout the pandemic in my
opinion but mainly because he was guilty
of breaking his own guidelines in a very
severe way after telling people for the
better part of two years to socially
distance and not see their loved ones he
of course was caught being very intimate
with a loved one so we do have to take
all of this with a pinch of salt we do
have to look at it in the context of
Matt Hancock trying to point the blame
at others and insisting that the way
that he handled the pandemic is not what
he's asking for forgiveness for we must
interrogate that and question that in
this case however I'm not sure that um
we can accuse him of just dishing out
these contracts to baroness Mona
actually sounds like he did pushback uh
so just very quickly before we move on
do you think that he has successfully
rehabilitated himself with the British
public
well it's really it's really strange
right because everywhere on social media
and everywhere if you asked people
you know there was no surge of
popularity for him in I'm a celebrity
and yet he finished in the top three so
there were a lot of shy Matt Hancock
fans who weren't saying they were fans
but they were seeing him as like a kind
of you know troubled bloke who did his
best
um I think that's pretty much the story
of the concert of the kind of classic
conservative voter now that they don't
ever say they're going to vote
conservative but then somehow they
managed to
um and I think there's a lesson in there
for people kind of celebrating too soon
that the conservatives have finished as
a government there are a lot of people
who are prepared to give them the
benefit of the doubt sorry I'm going to
stay with you because we've momentarily
lost uh Kate I'm afraid so let's move on
to the guardian and this story that we
read that people in the UK are getting
sicker and poorer with a gaping health
and wealth divide between the regions
that is getting worse this is according
to research from the ippr think tank
yeah so the ibbr I mean it's it's known
as a think tank that's sort of Center
left but I think it's also known as a
very kind of neutral
um sober organization and when they come
out with figures like this you need to
take them seriously because they're
certainly not doing it from a kind of
partisan perspective the amount of
long-term sickness which is you know
really keeping people out of the
workplace is astronomical we've known
that for quite a long time 700 000 extra
people out of the workforce because
they're just not well enough but what
this report shows is how regionally
determined that is so you're seeing kind
of people in the Northwest much more
likely to be out of work for ill health
than people in the Southeast and in
London now the thing is you've got to
bear in mind at this point just how
unlivable benefits are after 12 years of
austerity and just how difficult it is
to be on disability or sickness benefits
you know because the the constraints are
so tight the the demands are so
stringent that people are genuinely
struggling to keep themselves alive on
the Social Security support that they
have so
it it makes a mockery of the leveling up
agenda you know not only did it not
happen Not only was nothing constructive
done but in the absence of any kind of
sincere and directed policy Regional
divides have got much much worse over
the past five years and worse generally
over the past 12 years yes the Divide
does seem to be widening at a pace
economic inactivity because of sickness
is at its highest level we read Kate
since records began with 2.5 million
working age adults inactive because of
their poor health
yes this number is terrifying although I
have to meant not completely surprising
The Spectator has calculated that
roughly 5.2 million people of working
age
um are are out of work altogether at the
moment at the moment and on some kind of
out of work benefit and I don't think we
should be terribly surprised at the
waiting list at over 7 million
appointments on NHS England alone and
having the National Health Service
essentially become the national coveted
service for well more than a year closer
to two uh that we now find out that it's
roughly 2.5 million people who are
inactive because of a long-term health
condition
um you know these are terrifying numbers
and the very hard reality is that the
government expects these figures to go
up higher before they go back down the
estimate at the moment is that by March
2024 that waiting list will be 9 million
um you know this is no way for people to
live especially if they're in long-term
pain I think it is interesting this
report over the weekend that they're
going to recruit pharmacies to help uh
better medicate people and make access
to Medicine especially at that lower
level so I leave easier I think all of
this adds up to a genuine rethink about
how we provide Health Care in the UK and
the fact that lots of countries struggle
with their health services during the
pandemic but they don't have waiting
lists like this and until we can get
those 2.5 million people back into work
we should expect inflation figures to
stay higher because of course those
labor shortages are contributing to that
domestic service crunch in that
inflation that we're experiencing let's
go inside the Metro now page two on the
nurses strike Zoe take us into this
story
so
um it's it's it cannot be over stressed
how
incredible it is that the nurses are
going on strike at all you know it's
it's ABS it's a Black Swan event it's
never happened in the history of the
nurses Union it's never it's very rarely
even been kind of part of the discussion
around what kind of industrial pressure
they can put on the government
um so it's it's really a it's really
really and then
comes out with this line that that by
asking for a pay rise and by threatening
a strike they're playing into the hands
of Vladimir Putin now never mind that
that that it's completely irrelevant to
Vladimir Putin whether or not British
nurses are on strike and whether what
their payoffer is it particularly pecant
and insulting from the Nadeem zahawi
given that his own property portfolio is
valued at between 100 and 300 million
pounds you know and we have this again
and again and again with this really
extraordinary government of unbelievably
rich people you know it's like as a
nation we're just not used is his is his
property portfolio relevant though Zoe
extremely relevant when you've got
somebody lecturing a huge Workforce on
just keeping their pay at the level of
inflation so bear in mind they're not
asking for they're not asking to be
richer they're just asking to keep their
heads above water and you have somebody
saying even in asking for that you're
playing into the hands of a foreign
authoritarian waging a European War I
mean it just goes I think it really cuts
to the heart of the way in which Tory
cabinet ministers at the moment seem
completely disconnected from what
ordinary people think and how Ordinary
People live okay do you think Nadeem
zahari misspoke
I think he overstepped the Mark um I
don't think nurses should be going on
strike this December I think the ask of
almost a 20 pay increase is too much uh
and I think that they are genuinely
putting lives on the line by taking this
action that being said I think the
cabinet secretary has mishandled this
completely in the way that he's worded
this it is not playing into the hands of
the foreign dictator Zoe says to ask for
more pay or to request more pay
especially when inflation is making us
all feel significantly poor
um you know I don't think that
individuals honest reading of their
situation which is that you know for a
lot of people they're wondering if they
can even pay the bills this winter I
don't think to suggest that questioning
that and asking your employer for a pay
raise is playing into the hands of
Vladimir Putin
um and I I just think he's made a
mistake because
um ultimately uh when when nurses if
they do go on strike this December and
it looks like they're set to
um a lot is going to come down as to
whether or not the government looks like
it's trying to work with the nurses or
whether or not they're trying to work
against them and I think any government
that seemed to be trying to talk to them
trying to win them on side trying to
come to a more reasonable pay agreement
we'll be seeing quite well in the eyes
of the public especially when they have
been deprived those NHS services and
many people are going to be very
frustrated that people aren't showing up
to work to play catch-up but if it does
you know these fighting words from
zahawi I think are going to get the
government into more trouble than it
really needs to get into they're going
to look less reasonable than they
otherwise would if they kept the
language friendly and continue to point
out that an almost 20 pay increase is
simply not feasible at this time uh
welcome back to the Press preview still
with me Zoe Williams and Kate Andrews
taking us through the papers there they
both are let us have a look at um the ft
and the the picture there is a Cyril
ramaphosa um smiling broadly but he
doesn't really have very much to smile
about does he Kate
no the South the South African president
as the Ft says is fighting for his
political life after Scandal has been
revealed over the theft on his uh game
farm and he has said that he is leaving
the stuff to the up to that African
National conv Congress as to which way
they're going to determine his political
fate
um but it is certainly an uncomfortable
time for him and the route was coming
just weeks before the party was to hold
a leadership vote so um you know very
poor timing for him and big questions
over the future of leadership in South
Africa yes and what do we make of that
um Zoe because he he is coming from that
that traditional ANC background uh will
have worked with with Nelson Mandela but
a very different era now we're seeing in
South African politics
I mean there is there is a kind of
constant and and it is let's not forget
a relatively new Democratic culture in
South Africa really I mean it might feel
like a long time but it's actually not
that long in democracy of terms since
apart I ended and it and it and it is
very very painful for the political
landscape to see it beset by corruption
allegations you know whatever stage they
get to and whatever stage they get to in
the legal proceedings it's just
extremely painful to see all the hope of
the new democracy kind of solid like
this so yeah I I do think it's I do
think it's a really sad time in the
nation's political recent history
yes and Kate we read that he
he came to to power on a reputation as a
reformer
um and on a pledge to restore what's
described as clean government
I think so it makes an important point
about the difficulties there even in
very developed democracies when there's
Scandal it can certainly cause a rupture
it can cause you know I mean just look
at the United States as it was trying to
hand over power
um after the 2020 election very
established democracies uh can have
their own struggles when it comes to
this kind of corruption but if you're
talking about a relatively new democracy
that is even younger and even more
vulnerable to these kinds of things
especially when promises have been made
about integrity and and you know
creating a much cleaner system and it
can really shake things up so uh yeah
you know a a very difficult Revelation
and one that the African National
Congress you know we can only hope will
make the right call on to re-establish
trust in that system let's move on to
the Daily Mail and another photograph of
wide Grins and these we were hoping that
we would see they have gone through talk
us through this Zoe did you watch the
game
I I really want to sound like a football
expert
that I won't all I could speak is the
bit of the country that doesn't really
follow it but is happy that everybody
else is happy all I can say is everybody
does seem to be really really happy you
know it's like they they a lot of people
weren't expecting to lose to Senegal but
there was just enough suspense that it
was really exciting and then the win was
very resounding apparently I mean look
at them it's just it's just enough to
put anyone
um so obviously it's not it would be
better if we were playing France later
in the tournament because they're
probably the best other team left in the
tournament
um Twitter football thinks that France
has got the edge betting football
Edge so um all we can do is wait and see
that was expert analysis I think
it's really good I'm sorry what did you
did you watch first of all Zoe
oh okay I mean sorry I meant Kate
actually I'm looking at you and saying
uh Zoe Kate
um I did uh and I can speak through the
part of the country that is by Nomi's
football expert and cannot do proper
analysis on this but uh is watching and
is extremely excited and following along
um and it strikes me that we're now just
getting into heartbreak Zone uh where uh
we're excited enough that if things
start to go badly wrong and they go
wrong very quickly uh we will be a
heartbroken Nation once again
um but very exciting that England's
playing France next weekend uh and with
their you know if they can carry on
their performance today into next
weekend uh we can feel pretty good um
but you know there are no guarantees and
you know these knockout rounds in
football they're extremely exciting and
extremely tense
um I was watching uh I was watching the
match but uh I don't actually need to
because I can also hear when we've done
well or done badly from my local Club
down in Redwood the screams and shouts
are so loud I know when we've scored
absolutely
um you started off so positive and then
you had to go and mention heartbreak
don't say yes we have to prepare oh no
no let's just be positive let's just be
positive Speak Life and success into it
and it shall come to be thank you both
for taking us through the papers